if water is the source of life here in
lisbrooka De francoli the lack of water
has become a way of life
Juanita Perez has had to rethink how she
runs her business since restrictions
were posed in the village
yes because we are used to open the tap
and have water now at 7 pm and I don't
have a drop coming out it's complicated
and if one day you don't think about it
then you don't have water now I prepare
and I have water to wash dishes because
otherwise I wouldn't be able to do
anything
it hasn't rained here in months and the
frankly river is completely dry for
centuries it had allowed the village to
thrive
Catalonia is facing the most severe
drought in living memory and water
scarcity is an ever-growing problem as
the summer season approaches
sewage has become part of the solution
that dark opaques stinky liquid grows
through a purification process and
eventually becomes drinkable water it's
hard to imagine but that's what happens
to the sewage of about 2 million people
on a daily basis
the water treatment plant has been
working at full capacity for the past
year 200
000 cubic meters that's the same as 50
Olympic swimming pools are regenerated
and purified every day enough clean
water for up to 1.5 million people a day
regenerating the used water can solve
part of the problem from my point of
view without regenerating water we
wouldn't have many options to solve our
current problem people in this pluga de
francoli rely on water deliveries 10
tankers a day carrying on average 25
000 liters Each Coming For Now from a
natural source but it's not sustainable
and people here know that how to use
water efficiently has become a main
topic of conversation you always have to
think as in a situation like now you
have to think that the water is limited
and we have to the water as oil
we must understand that water is more
important than gas because without water
there's no possible life for humans
more than 400 municipalities face water
restrictions Alternatives help alleviate
the problem across Catalonia people are
praying for rain but for now their
prayers go unanswered Abdul Hamid
al-jazeera Catalonia